Hallo und herzlich willkommen zum Podcast UFO 2016 mit Stefan Tietze.
Hey, wie geht's euch da draußen? Seid ihr gut drauf? Ich bin gut drauf. Florentin ist am Start, Stefan ist am Start und wir haben heute Spaß, wie ich euch das sag. Ich kann es nicht zurückhalten, ich kann mich nicht beherrschen, ich muss es jetzt schon sagen, wir waren gestern auf dem Comedypreis 2016. Oh! Heute, der grosse Comedypreis 2016, Recap, wir lassen den Abend, wir durchleben den Abend mit euch nochmal neu, würde ich sagen, einfach um die ganzen Erlebnisse mit euch zu teilen, es war wieder herausragend, dieser Abend, der ist so voll gespickt mit tollen Ereignissen. Also für jeden Comedy-Freund ist das wirklich ein Hochgenuss, ein
17-Gänge-Menü, wo man am Ende sagt,
ach, jetzt bin ich aber satt.
Jetzt will ich für ein Jahr lang nichts mehr
essen und vor allem nicht in Deutschland.
Wurde auch nicht mehr lachen.
Ich hab seitdem auch nicht mehr gelacht.
Es war eine Menge los, wir haben eine fantastische,
viele Leute angesprochen, die vielleicht in den Podcast
kommen können. Ihr dürft euch also
in den nächsten Folgen auf Promi-Alarm freuen.
Ja, Promi-Alarm, aber nicht im positiven Sinne, sondern also meistens in so einem, ach, okay, mal gucken.
Es ist eher so eine Art Promi-Jumpscare. Aber es kommen viele Promis ironisch, also wir laden viele ironisch ein.
Ja. Wie meinst du Jumpscare? Ja, eher so ein, und hier ist Ralf Schmitz! Ja, und dann sind es erschrocken, was, in meinem Podcast? Ja. Es wird echt ein bisschen seltsam, glaube ich, in den nächsten Wochen. Es wird merkwürdig, das wird immer so eine Party und dann die nächsten Tage merkt man, dass ein paar Gäste immer noch da sind. Dann hast du immer noch so DJ Bobo im Schrank oder sowas und du räumst auf und hast dann irgendwie Celine Dion unter dem Tisch und denkst dir, Leute,
komm, aber Celine,
aber Celine, bleib. Aber das Ding
ist, ich habe gestern,
was ich nie wollte, bekomme ich den Preis,
es ist mir wirklich unangenehm auch,
ich habe eine Visitenkarte bekommen
von so einem Promoter-Typen,
so Manager von mehreren, Manager von
verschiedenen Leuten, unter anderem Max Gehrmann und so einen Scheiss
und Bastian Pasefka und der hat mir seine Karte gegeben, weil ich ihm das Projekt vorgestellt habe. Und er meinte, ja cool, die können alle mal zu euch kommen. Und hat mir dann seine Karte gegeben, so mega old-fashioned. Warum gibt man noch Karten, wenn man einfach E-Mail-Adressen geben kann? Das Tolle ist, bei Podcasts kann man ja ohne weiteres einfach bluffen. Wenn man sagt, okay, unser Podcast wird von 500.000 Leuten gehört, kann das keiner. Nee, niemand kann es überiemand, schlicht niemand. Nicht mal wir wissen, wie viele Leute uns hören und wir können einfach behaupten, was wir wollen. Und gerne diese ganzen Oldschool-Manager, diese ganzen Leute, die ihre Leute verschachern, haben keine Ahnung davon. Leute, die Visitenkarten verteilen, würden niemals dahinter kommen, ob wir lügen oder nicht beim Podcast zuhören. Aber das war echt strange. Da habe ich dann meinen Anzug getan, so businessmäßig, oben mit dieser Tasche. Mit dem ganzen Schokobomb-Papierchen drin. Wo der Knopf noch zu war. Das Problem hatte ich gestern auch, ja. Und diese Nick-Nacks noch drin waren. Das war echt ein bisschen unangenehm. Aber die Karte habe ich mit raus, war Krümel dran. Aber ich glaube, da ruhig mal an bei der Nummer.
Wir sind dort im Podcast-Studio, wir sind wieder umgezogen,
wir haben ein neues, wurde uns ein Podcast-Studio
gebaut. Das ist jetzt schon das
fünfte
Studio, das wir aufnehmen. Mega professionell,
also wir haben auch so
Dinger, so Arme, die uns,
wo man das Mikrofon sich so zu sich
ziehen kann, aber der Ort
ist nicht so clever gewählt, also das ist direkt neben der Küche und auch keine Wand quasi. Neben dem Maschinenraum, ja. Das gleich geht vielleicht so ein Motor an und dann haben wir ein Problem. Ich habe mir heute mal Gedanken gemacht über das Thema Comedypreis, weil Comedypreis natürlich ist eine Farce, müssen wir überhaupt nicht drüber reden, kompletter Schwachsinn. Eine Farce! Aber die Frage ist, könnte man man einen vernünftigen Comedypreis machen?
Und dann habe ich mir überlegt, warum... Die Antwort ist ja.
Ich weiß nicht, also es gibt ja zum Beispiel
Filmkritiker, wo man einfach sagt,
okay, die machen selber keine Filme,
deren Job ist es, Filme anzuschauen und
alle Filme zu kennen und dadurch und
auch durch die Theorie und sowas einfach
zu diskutierter Meinungen kommen. Also du willst einen Haufen Stefan Schwers
hinsetzen, die Comedykritiker.
Die Comedykritiker brauchen, die aber dann alles kennen, aber das ist eher schwer vorstellbar, Comedy-Kritiker. Wahrscheinlich, weil es dann irgendwie doch noch zu subjektiv ist. Aber Film ja tendenziell eher auch. Da geht es auch um Humor, da geht es ja schon Filmtheorie und die Geschichte und wie sie das entwickelt hat. Aber Comedy-Unterhaltungstheorie gibt es auch alles. Naja, weiß ich nicht. Also warum gibt es denn keine Comedy-Kritiker? Warum ist das denn kein Thing, dass man akzeptiert, ah okay, der Marcel Reich-Kanitzki, der der Comedy-Szenen. Nein, die heißen noch nicht so, das sind dann Fernsehkritiker oder so ein Hans-Hoff-Typen. Das sind im weitesten Sinne, glaube ich, die Comedy-Kritiker. Aber ich fühle mich von dem nicht vertreten. Ich würde auf dessen Meinung nicht viel geben. Wenn der sagt, hier irgendwie Knallerfrauen ist gut, dann sage ich, ja. Wobei ich gestern sagte, ich hätte Comedy-Kritiker gefunden, nämlich Comedians selber, weil das ist die schlimmste, derdenkliche Möglichkeit eines Publikums für Comedy-Veranstaltungen sind nur Komiker, ein Meer aus Komikern, mit ihren bunten Frisuren, mit den lustigen Blumen, wo Wasser rausspritzt, mit den lustigen gross zu russischen Schuhen, ha ha ha ha.
Und dann steht er so ein Max Gehmer auf der Bühne, rackelt sich den Arsch ab, um eine Pointe zu bekommen und niemand lacht, weil alle versessen darauf sind, selber eigentlich da oben zu stehen. Und das Problem ist halt, dass es in Deutschland so wenige Comedians gibt, es gibt halt irgendwie sechs Comedians, von denen sitzen vier in der Jury, das heißt, das Ganze ist halt irgendwie schon ein bisschen sinnlos. Und da fängt es, glaube ich, an mit unserem grossen Recap. Punkt eins. Dieter Nuhr ist der Jury-Präsident und er hat gestern zwei Preise gewonnen. Und ich habe gehört, das läuft so ab. Also, die treffen sich morgens am Tag des Preises, trifft sich eine auserlesene Jury aus Leuten aus der Comedy und aus Produktionsfirmen und so weiter und die sind in Auftrag von RTL und Brainpool passiert das. So, man kann sich also schon fragen, warum gewinnen so viele Brainpool und RTL-Formate, aber geschenkt. So, dann sitzen da Leute und Dieter Nuhe ist der Jury-Präsident seit Jahren. Und dann reden die über die Formate, die nominiert sind und dann entstehen halt so Gespräche und wir haben auch ein paar Insider, die berichtet haben, wie das darin abläuft.
Und das ist echt lustig, weil
die reden dann über die Formate und
ziehen auch darüber her und so. Und dann meinte
ein Kollege von uns, dass er jemanden kennt, der schon mal
da drin saß, der dann irgendwann
sich in der Situation wiederfand, wo sein Format
massiv gelästert wurde. Und er meinte dann
irgendwann so, ey, sorry, ey, ist ja okay,
wenn ihr es nicht gut fand, aber könnt ihr bitte aufwählen, ich hab das Format betreut als Redakteur, könnt ihr bitte aufwählen, das so niederzumachen? Und dann meinten die, ja, okay. Und dann hat er gewonnen. Sein Format hat gewonnen. Und es war das Format, wo er gesagt hat, bitte hören auf, niederzumachen. Und das ist der Comedypreis in Nutshell. Das ist schon extrem merkwürdig, weil es halt auch wirklich am Tag davor von sehr wenigen Menschen in so einer subjektiven Stellen Sache entschieden. Und man hat auch bei so Sachen, bei so Familie Braun hat gewonnen, hat zum Beispiel gewonnen gegen das Lachen der anderen und gegen Ponyhof, gegen durchaus anschaubare Sendungen haben die gewonnen, wo man sich, und Familie Braun ist schrecklich, wo man sich wahrscheinlich auch denkt, so, ah, okay, Anti-Nazi, Toleranz, Botschaft, okay, komm, lass uns das nur weiter. Mit der Geschichte, wo einfach alle sagen, das ist scheiße. Mit der Geschichte, wie du, jetzt müssen wir kurz den Abend spoilern, wie du am Ende Familie Braun den Comedypreis geklaut hast. Das ist ein anderes Thema. Finde ich, eigentlich ziemlich lustig, du siehst nicht ein, du lässt dich den gewinnen und willst dich selber, vor allem der Comedypreis zum Thema Innovation. Ich finde, wenn wir was verdient hätten, dann den Comedypreis für Innovation. Ja, aber das ist wirklich merkwürdig, aber auch ansonsten, was wir da gesehen haben, auch an Moderation und Laudation, man hat wirklich das Gefühl, wir bewegen uns wieder zurück. Also wirklich, man muss das nicht so kurz darauf eingehen, aber auch dieser Sexismus und diese Frauenfeindlichkeit in fast jeder einzelnen Moderation war wirklich erdrückend. Da hattest du wirklich dann Leute da, die gesagt haben dann, ah ja, es ist ja nur ein Vorurteil, dass Frauen nicht lustig sein können. Das stimmt überhaupt nicht. Ich meine, habt ihr mal eine beim Einpacken zugeschaut? Und der einzige Pointe davon war dann nur noch zu sagen, ah, jetzt habe ich ja mit meinem Gag über die Frauenfeindlichkeit, habe ich ja jetzt irgendwie Leute dazu bewegt, darüber nachzudenken. Und das war's, aber das ist nicht so. Und es ist einfach von vorne bis an Frauenveracht.
Dass halt immer noch diese leicht bekleideten Frauen auf die Bühne kommen und ihnen die Preise geben und trotzdem alle wirklich in der, das ist wirklich so widersprüchlich. Enissa Armani wurde anmoderiert mit Sie ist hot, sie ist lustig, Enissa Armani.
Ja, sie ist hot, sie ist cool, hier ist Enissa Armani.
Und wo du einfach denkst, okay, und in jeder Laudatio zu Frauen wird konstant betont, dass es Frauen sind, aber auch gleichzeitig, dass sie es schaffen, mehr als nur eine Frau zu sein. Es ist ja immer toll, dass es bei ihr nicht nur darum geht, dass sie eine Frau ist, aber es ist ja toll, dass jetzt auch mal eine Frau lustig ist. Und die Gags wurden von Männern gemacht, nur. Und ich verstehe immer nicht, ich dachte kurz, der Abend hat sich wie so ein Pendel bewegt, zwischen ermahnend zu sagen, frauenfeindlich ist das Letzte, wo ich mir denke, braucht es diese Botschaft noch in 2016? Aber das andere, dann pendelt es zurück zur anderen Seite, wo massiv frauenfeindlich geredet wurde. Es war wirklich so ein Pendel aus Warum reden die noch über Frauen, über Sexismus im Jahr 2016, indem du so, ah, deswegen. Ja, genau. Aber auf der anderen Seite kann man ja sagen, ist ja durchaus okay, frauenfeindliche Gäste zu machen, aber dann mit dieser konstanten Hin und Her Bewegung, dieses Ganze, aber davon ja eigentlich nicht, weil Frauen sind ja auch so okay und wir reden nicht ständig darüber, dass Frauen so sind, aber dann tun sie es doch die ganze Zeit. Also das ist selber so
widersprüchlich. Die nehmen sich in der Botschaft, die sie
selber geben, nicht ernst, weil wenn sie sich ernst nehmen
würden, wäre es einfach egal und man würde einfach sagen,
hier, besser Komiker, dann, beste Komikerin,
dann und nicht immer, ah, jetzt müssen wir extra noch mal
über Frauen reden, jetzt wo wir in der weiblichen Komik sind.
Und auch das könnte man alles noch verzeihen, wenn es wenigstens
ein bisschen lustig wäre, aber das sind auch leider
alles Gags und das meine ich jetzt gar nicht
so, das könnte ich alles viel besser, aber es ist alles halt hat man schon mal gehört so. Wenn man sich so ein bisschen mit Comedy auseinandersetzt, hat man jeden Gag gestern schon mal in einer, wenn dann nur leicht abgeänderten Form mindestens schon mal gehört. Ja. Auch, dass der Gag zweimal gestern gemacht wurde, was ich schon lustig finde, dass zweimal ein Gag gemacht wird, der gleiche, und zwar der kommt ein Zyklop zum Augearzt. Ja, das war so ein bisschen so ein Insider, der wurde letztes Jahr gemacht und da hat er anscheinend nicht gut funktioniert. Und dann hat sich früher nochmal gesagt, da wusste ich schon, dass der nicht funktioniert und dann hat er nicht funktioniert und jetzt will ich aber, dass er funktioniert und ich erkläre ihn euch nochmal, ganz cringy, ganz, ganz schrecklich teilt, die meisten werden es sich nicht angeschaut haben, aber ganz schrecklich. Also in der Theorie ist die Veranstaltung perfekt. Es gibt kostenloses Essen, es laufen nur in der Theorie. Ja, nach der Veranstaltung gab es Essen. Da bin ich, habe mich aber richtig mal in die Brennnessel gesetzt. Laufen nur lustige Menschen rum, es laufen Maccafe-Damen rum, die die ganze Zeit einem Donuts ins Gesicht schieben. Dann gibt es sämtliche Dinge kostenlos. Käse. Es gibt Käse, es gibt Red Bull kostenlos, Club Mate kostenlos, Fritz Kohle, diese ganzen Endorsements gibt es dann halt da. Und da fragt man sich dann wirklich immer jedes Jahr, warum hat man dann danach so wenig Bock auf diese Party, weil die ist dann Theorie perfekt, aber davor die Veranstaltung gesorgt, dann so viel Energie raus. Das stimmt, ja. Ich bin dann von der Veranstaltung auf diese Party gegangen und dachte mir so, deswegen hältst du es nicht so lange aus. Ich frage mich jedes Jahr aufs Neue, warum, aber in der Theorie echt genial ist. Und es ist vor allem auch alles Fake, da gab es dann wahnsinnig viel Käse und da waren dann so Dekorationen, so ganze Käseleibe präsentiert. Davon wollte ich einen Clown, stellt sich raus, die sind gar nicht echt. Das ist einfach nur so eine Plastikhülle, das ist gar kein echter Käseleib gewesen. Sprich, sind die Comedians auch quasi nur so ein Plastikleib eines Comedians? Ich hab mir echt mal ein bisschen ... Was ist jetzt hier passiert? Ich hab mir überlegt, weil ich glaube, es gibt einfach nur zwei Arten von diesen Comedians, die scheiße sind. Die einen, die sich darüber im Klaren sind, aber so einen machen auf, das ist ja das, was die Leute wollen. Wer ist das zum Beispiel? Ich glaube, Mario Barth zum Beispiel. Ich glaube, Atze Schröder. Ja, aber auch bei Mario Barth finde ich, ist es immer ganz klar, weil Mario Barth hat auch einen Preis gewonnen für die erfolgreichste Stand-Up-Tour, also nicht mal beste, sondern einfach nur meistens Geld. Den er jedes Jahr gewinnt. Jedes Jahr, meistens Geld. Und dann kommt sein Film, wie er es annimmt, und er steht vor Publikum. Er bedankt sich bei seinem Publikum, das ist mein Publikum, das sind die Leute, also dieses konstante Verweisen auf die Leute, die einfachen Leute. Die Leute, die kaufen das. Ich glaube, genau so sieht er das auch. Wenn du ihn wirklich in einem privaten 1 zu 1 Gespräch reden würdest, würde er wahrscheinlich sagen, das ist alles scheiße, was ich mache, aber das wollen halt einfach die Leute. Und mein Job ist es, die Leute zum Lachen zu bringen. Ich glaube nicht, ob es bei Mario Barth so ist. Aber dann entwickelt er sich weiter. Also ich glaube, mit diesem Wissen, mit dieser Reflektierter, die du gerade ihm unterstellst, entwickelt er sich leider automatisch einfach weiter. Nein, ich glaube, es gibt Menschen, ich glaube, es er nicht so bleiben. die haben schlicht keinen Anspruch. Die stellen sich auf die Bühne, sagen fünf Gags und sagen am Ende des Abends, die drei Gags, die am meisten Lacher hatten, sind gut. Die definieren Qualität einfach durch Feedback des Publikums. Und so machen die ihre gesamte Karriere und machen immer wieder neue Gags und dann lachen die Leute. Das machen ja professionelle und gute Comedians in Anführungszeichen auch, aber die haben vielleicht noch eine eigene Botschaft, die sagen, ah, den würde ich gerne machen und ich fände es mal cool, wenn jemand so einen Gag macht und machen nicht immer nur den dümmsten Gag der Welt. Und ich glaube, da gibt es andere, die machen es eben genau so und haben am Ende einfach ein neunzigminütiges Programm, wo du einfach als Normaldenkender Mensch da sitzt und die Augen rollst, aber die normale Masse, die Assis, lachen sich kaputt und der denkt sich auch, okay, die dann so dieses volksnahe
Denken haben, so, oh, die sollen auch lachen
und ich spreche die normalen Probleme der einzelnen
Leute an. Aber wie großartig war dann
wieder sein Dankesrede auch, wo er meinte,
ja, ich glaube, ich gehe dieses Jahr gar
nicht auf Tour, dann haben die anderen auch mal
eine Chance. Ja, genau, was einerseits
so ein
Er trifft natürlich mega den Kern eigentlich auch.
40% Gag, glaube ich, ist aber auch ein guter Teil
nicht, weil es stimmt ja schlicht auch.
Das ist ja auch das Problem. Das gleiche Problem
Vielen Dank. Er trifft natürlich mega den Kern eigentlich auch. So ein 40% Gag, glaube ich, ist aber auch ein guter Teil nicht, weil es stimmt ja schlicht auch. Das ist ja auch das Problem. Das gleiche Problem zum Beispiel ist mit Karolin Kebekus. Wenn man jetzt nochmal auf die weibliche Seite der Comedians gehen möchte, warum gibt es zu wenig oder warum kommen die nicht nach? Weil jedes Jahr immer nur Karolin Kebekus gewinnt. Jedes Jahr. Es ist immer nur, es gibt männliche Comedians und es gibt Karolin Kebekus. und media bös,, die noch nie jedes Jahr nominiert ist. Man sieht sie immer oben, eine ganz eigene Geschichte für sich, eine ganz eigene Welt. Diese Welt, in der die Nominierten eingeblendet werden, von den Kameras eingefangen werden. Und die dann halt media Böse nie gewinnt, das aber auch weiss. Die kann auch die Kamera wegwinken. Die ist so bezahltes Kanonenfutter, die einfach da ist und genau weiß, dass sie nicht genommen wird. Inissa Armani war auch da, glaube ich, aber gar nichts gewonnen, irgendwie Kristall, besser nachvoll. Aber ich glaube, dass der Comedypreis hält sich selber am Leben. Das ist so das Ding, wenn der weg wäre. Es ist eine komplette Werbeveranstaltung für die Dinge, die RTL und Brainpool produzieren. Ja, sicher. Das ist ja auch kein Preis, das ist ja eine Sendung. Der Preis ist ja zweitrangig. Es geht ja nur darum, eine Sendung zu haben, die Leute sich anschauen. Ich glaube, Mia Bös wird von sich selber am Leben, also von diesem Mechanismus, der ist am Leben gehalten. Ich glaube, wenn sie nicht mehr bei RTL wäre oder so, dann wäre es vorbei, dann niemand würde mich mehr dafür interessieren. Ich glaube, es ist so eine Selbsterhaltung, die sich gerade da irgendwie, also es wird einem vorgegaukelt, dass die erfolgreich sind und deswegen sind sie erfolgreich. Ich glaube, wenn man aufhören würde, ich habe auch nie irgendwas von dem Fernsehen gesehen, aber es lief dann ein zehnmündiger Zusammenschnitt. Ja doch, bei diesem Sat.1-Dinger da, die ballern schon auch viele Sendungen. Es ist ja auch erstaunlich, wie viele Sendungen man da sieht, die man noch nie erlebt hat. Da gab es teilweise ganze Kategorien, wo ich keine einzige Sendung je gesehen habe. Also es gibt da schon eine Menge irgendwie, die da das rausballern. Die brauchen halt auch Leute. Also du machst dann so eine Panel-Show, so oh, jetzt ist der Boden schief, da brauchen wir in jeder Folge drei neue Promis. Du brauchst diese Industrie, braucht halt auch Gesichter, die einfach dann die hinstellt. Und der Comedypreis braucht sich Gesichter. Und ich glaube, dass manchmal wird der Erfolg von Leuten behauptet, damit die nächstes Jahr da auch noch sein können. Und ich glaube, mehr Bös ist sowas. Und ich glaube auch, Olivia Jones ist sowas. Die ist schon echt lange im Geschäft. Die hatte hier mit 30 cm im Leben ein kleiner Peter, die hatte damals auch schon so Hits und so mit so Assis-Sounds und so. Das war von der? Was? Ach Gott, ey. Ach Gott. Und das sind genau die Leute, die den Comedypreis schmeißen. Aber es ist jetzt auch so manchmal, dass du da rumläufst und ich finde das ganz seltsam, wenn du dann so dich von deiner Gruppe trennst und dann zum Klo gehst oder zum Buffet gehst, was sie da für Gestalten entgegenkommen. Und ich finde, das ist so eine tote Veranstaltung manchmal. Auch da kommt dann am Anfang so ein Warm-Upper, der das Ganze erklärt. Und da ist ja nur die Industrie, die jedes Jahr da sind. Die treffen sich jedes Jahr zum Comedypreis, pünktlich im Oktober da. Und da müsste niemand mehr erklären, wie das läuft. Die stehen alle auf, wenn sie genau wissen, jetzt wird der Sonderpreis verliehen, da steht man auf, dann steht die ganze Industrie auf. Das sind diese Automatismen und alles geschieht mit diesen toten Augen. Und alle haben auch, wer da moderiert, ist scheißegal, was er für Gags macht, ist scheißegal. Wenn der Sonderpreis verlieren wird, stehen wir alle auf. Danach geht's pünktlich zum Buffet. Leute gehen auch einfach, obwohl man auch niemand hat irgendwie den Anschein erweckt, dass die Veranstaltung vorbei sein könnte. Leute gehen, weil die Leute wissen, jetzt kann man gehen. Das ist wie beim Flieger, wo irgendwann mal einer aufgestanden ist zu früh und dann sind alle aufgestanden und denkt, okay, jetzt kann man wohl aufstehen. Das ist da genauso, das ist ganz, ganz seltsam. Und diese toten Menschen, die haben so Matze Knob, der mit so einem eingefallenen Gesicht. Genau, der auch einfach nur geduldet wird und der auch einfach seit acht Jahren nicht mehr zu sehen war, aber den man da als Gesicht erwartet und erkennt und der ist da, aber
machen tut der auch nicht mehr viel, ne, und
aber ja, Max Gehrmann
ist auch einfach besser,
oder?
Ja.
Sind die beiden grossen
Parodisten in Deutschland?
Ja, das stimmt schon, ja. Was ist, äh, also Bill Hay, wer ist eher ein Bill Hayter? Der Max Gierman ist der deutsche Bill Hayter, klar. Ach Gott, ey. Ja, aber danach beginnt dann die Feier und die ist wirklich, ähm, die ist eigentlich immer grossartig, weil man immer mit Leuten spricht. Und wir haben gestern halt unsere Challenge auferlegt, mit Leuten zu quatschen. Wie machst du zum Beispiel? Wollen wir das sagen? Ich will da nicht spoilern, ich finde, das sollte in Erraschung bleiben, aber wir haben ein paar grosse Namen an Land gezogen, beziehungsweise sind awkward um grosse Namen den ganzen Abend herumgestreift, georbitet. Ja, aber das ist ein anderes Thema. Auf jeden Fall, wir freuen uns auf nächstes Jahr, wenn wir wieder dabei sind oder wenn wir vielleicht nominiert sind und dann nicht kommen können, weil wir keine Zeit haben, ist natürlich dann... Ich glaube, es ist auch so wirklich so, das ist... Comedypreis ist so lange interessant, bis du nominiert wirst, und dann kannst du dich nicht mehr blicken lassen. Aber wir müssen noch mal ein lustiges Moment gestern ansprechen. Bernhard Hohecker wurde eingeblendet als Nominierter, und zwar bei der Show, bei der wir beide mitgeschrieben haben, die unwahrscheinlichen Ereignisse im Leben von, liefem WDR Fernsehen, war nominiert für die beste Sketchshow. Und dann waren halt die Nominierten eingeblendet. Und das ist ja so ein bisschen SNL-ich gedacht, das Konzept, dass immer unterschiedliche Hosts das moderieren, die berühmt sind. Genau, pro Folge ein Promi, der ist moderiert. Und Bernhard Hohecker hat eine Folge moderiert und wurde dann als der Nominierte oben gezeigt, weil die niemanden aus dem Ensemble, was ja aus relativ unbekannten Leuten besteht, sag ich mal, wo uns ja ein bisschen Mühe geben könnte und einen von denen hätte zeigen können. Nein, die haben Bernhard Hohecker gezeigt als einer der Promis, der mal eine Show moderiert hat, haben es also komplett missverstanden schon. und dann war er halt nicht nominiert, wusste aber auch nicht, wie ihm geschah, weil er halt oben in diesem kleinen Bildschirm zu sehen war. Und es war mega unangenehm. Und dann hat die Sendung verloren. Und er hat sich auch ein bisschen geärgert. Ich glaube, er wusste nicht, wie er sich fühlen soll. Ich habe jetzt verloren, aber ich war nicht mehr nominiert. Wie lustig, als jemand, der nicht nominiert zu sein, als jemand, der nicht nominiert war, zu verlieren. Ich weiß noch, fast alle aus dem Assemble von die Oma Schenke eigentlich, sondern auch ich, sind dann in der Aftershow-Party alle einzeln zu mir gegangen und haben gesagt, Alter, es tut mir echt leid, dass nichts geworden ist. Komm, ey, nächstes Jahr. War nicht ein Jahr, war einfach nicht ein Jahr. Und er so, hey, ich habe damit nichts zu tun. Wir so, nee, Alter, ist schon okay, es lag echt nicht, da ist ja auch viel
Industrie und so, das ist ja auch immer viel
abgekapptes Spiel, echt nichts gegen
dich. Nächstes Jahr machst du das, die Show war
super.
Das war so ein cool Typ.
Vielleicht schon nochmal sorry an Christine Westermann,
ähm, also für den
Abend gestern, es tut mir einfach wahnsinnig leid.
Ja, da ist viel, viel falsch gelaufen.
Naja, naja, Comedypreis. Ja, ganz, ganz seltsam. Aber nächstes Jahr wieder, oder? Klar. Klar, ich meine, das ist der Comedypreis. Es ist schon lustig. Aber kann man ironisch zum Comedypreis gehen? Eigentlich nicht. Sobald du da drin bist, bist du in so einer Maschinerie. Man fühlt sich immer so dreckig, wie beim Porno gucken. Ich glaube, man kann generell nichts ironisch. Das ist nur eine Erklärung, die man sich selber gibt, um zu ertragen, dass man es ernsthaft tut. Wirklich ironisch, glaube ich, tut man nichts. Ja. Ach Gott, warte, warte, warte. Wir haben heute eine besondere Folge für euch verbreitet, denn wir haben eine Frage zu klären, ein für alle Mal. Und diese Frage lautet, warum können wir Dinge nicht einfach zusammendrücken? So, als kurze Erklärung. Also die ganze Welt, die wir sehen und auch Dinge, die wir nicht sehen, bestehen aus Atomen. Und die wiederum bestehen aus einem Atomkern und so gerösselt drumherum. Stellt euch das Zuckerwarten vor.
Gedönsel.
Gedönsel, ja.
So, und aus diesen Atomen, die sind in verschiedener Formation und Form und Farbe zusammengebunden.
Farbe weiß ich nicht.
Die sind so zusammengeflickt und dadurch entstehen dann Sachen.
So.
Die Naturwissenschaftler, ich höre das Augenrollen der Naturwissenschaftler unter euch von bis hierhin.
Und es gibt ja zwei Teile.
Es gibt den Atomkern, der zusammengehalten wird von der starken Wechselwirkung, starken Atomkraft und dann die Tatsache, dass sich zwei Atome abstossen oder Elektronen oder so ein Shit, weil die gleichzeitig oder anders geladen sind und es die schwache Wechselwirkung. Oder starke. Die Frage ist jetzt, die hängen ja zusammen, die Atome, in irgendeiner Weise. Also wenn du so einen Finger nimmst und dann stellst du dir die ganz äusserste Schicht deiner Haut vor, dann sind das ja im Endeffekt ganz viele einzelne Atome, die zusammengeklüht sind. Aber wie? Die sind durch magische Kräfte, halten die zusammen. Und die Frage ist, warum kannst du jetzt nicht einfach deinen anderen Finger nehmen und den dagegen drücken und dann bleiben die zusammenhängen? An dieser Stelle muss gesagt sein, dass man sich ja nicht, es wird schon wieder so eine ernste Folge, aber man kann sich nicht berühren. Also wenn du deinen einen Finger nimmst und den anderen Zeigefinger nimmst und die zusammendrückst, ist es eine Illusion, dass sie sich berühren. Die berühren sich überhaupt nicht. Ja, aber die Frage ist halt, was man damit berühren. Weil die einen Atomschichten, Molekülschichten und die anderen sich abstossen. Das heißt, diese Berührung, die ihr fühlt, ist eigentlich nur das Abstoßen der verschiedenen Atome. Ja, aber wenn du sagst, sie berühren sich nicht, was ist denn dann dazwischen? Da ist ganz, ganz, ganz wenig dazwischen. Aber was denn? Luft. Luft. Ja, ein bisschen Luft. Ja, aber Luft besteht doch auch aus Molekülen, Sauerstoff und so. Aber nicht so viel, weil es ja gaslich. Ich glaube, das ist nicht so viel. Ist ja egal. Ist ja nur damit, die wir jetzt verstehen. Ganz kurz. Also, dass man weiss, dass es sich nicht berührt, sondern dass man, also, ich glaube, es geht. Ich glaube, man kann sehr viele Dinge zusammendrücken, man muss halt nur sehr viel Energie aufwenden. Und da war jetzt meine, also ich glaube nämlich, dass man Gase, verschiedene Gase, die haben einen anderen Aggregatzustand, die sind, die haben weniger, die Dichte ist weniger gross. Da sind wir uns alle einig, oder? Weil wir laufen ja gerade durch die Luft. Also das kann schon mal, und ich glaube, Gase kann man deswegen sehr leicht zusammendrücken. Aber das ist ja nur ein Gasgemisch, wenn du zwei verschiedene Gase zusammen in einen Raum füllst. Ja, meine Güte. Das ist ja ein Gasgemisch. Aber das ist ja jetzt Kleinkrämerei, das ist ja eine Pingelei. Ja, da hast du recht. Das stimmt schon. Da haben sie recht, Herr Einstein. G ist gleich im Zirka-Draht. Ja mein Gott, da ist doch jetzt alles ping. Plus 0,141. Eija, komm, das schreit mal weg. Lass uns mal stecken. Das brauchen wir nicht. So, mit dieser Frage, warum kann man Dinge nicht einfach zusammendrücken, rufen wir unseren Physikexperten an. Mach mal auf laut, also richtig auf laut. Dr. Professor Philipp Hauptmann, denen wir diese Frage stellen werden und der mal wieder als wissenschaftlicher Expertengast, den wir herzlich in dieser Folge willkommen heißen. Handy braucht keinen Pop-Schutz, ne? Das Ding ist, er hat mich jetzt leider nicht, ne? Ach so, nicht. Na ja, gut. Du musst doch laut sein. Jubel, grüß dich. Hallo, du bist im Das-Podcast-Sufo-Podcast live, schon wieder. ich. Hallo, du bist im das Podcast-UFO-Podcast live, schon wieder, hallo. Ja, du bist gerade im Podcast-UFO, wir brauchen physikalischen Rat, wir haben eine Frage an dich. Die Frage ist, warum kann man Dinge nicht einfach zusammendrücken? Also, wenn ich meinen Finger auf meinen anderen Zeigefinger zubewege, warum werden die nicht zu einem Finger gemischt, sondern warum
bleiben das
zwei unterschiedliche Individuen?
Also es geht um Atome.
Die Atome innerhalb meines Zeigefingers werden
anscheinend durch irgendwelche magischen Kräfte zusammengehalten
und die in meinem Daumen auch.
Warum kann ich nicht meinen Finger und meinen Daumen
einfach zusammendrücken, sodass die
sich wiederum verbinden und nicht mehr auseinandergehen?
Oder geht es und ich brauche einfach mehr Energie? Ja, klar geht es. Du kannst alles, also was glaubst du denn, was passiert, wenn du Eisen schmelzt und zusammengiesst? Ja, das habe ich gestern auchokalisierte Elektronen, die das ganze energetisch sehr stabil machen und demzufolge musst du halt Energie reinstecken, um diese stabilen Zustände aufzubrechen. Das habe ich alles gestern gesagt. Das war eigentlich auch schon alles und wenn du genug Kraft aufwendest, kannst du dann sicher auch Finger zusammenpressen, aber davor wahrscheinlich bricht der aber nicht die Frau Knochen und dann wird ein bisschen eklig. Aber wenn du aus dem Fenster springst und sehr hoch fällst, weiß ich nicht genau, was da am Boden passiert. Aber wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel ein Blatt Papier habe und das in zwei Teile reiße und jetzt versuche ich die Teile einfach wieder zusammenzudrücken, sodass das Blatt Papier wieder genauso aussieht wie davor, geht das? Ja, es ist halt technisch und hier umzusetzen, aber grundsätzlich geht das schon natürlich. Du meinst ja grundsätzlich, dass du Atome verbindest. Das geht natürlich schon, aber du darfst nicht vergessen, dass man so ein Papier auseinanderreißt. Diese Gerissstellen sind natürlich dann auch wieder ein bisschen anders. Ja, aber warum? Also das ist natürlich alles technisch. Aber bei der Produktion des Papiers hat man die ja dann zusammengedrückt oder so. Und diese Energie kann man ja auch wieder aufwenden, um es wieder zusammenzupressen. Also müsste es ja eigentlich funktionieren, wenn das nicht alles beim Reisprozess verschoben hätte, oder? Ja, klar. Also ganz theoretisch gesagt, ja. Aber wie gesagt, technisch umzusetzen, ist es eher schwierig. Ist es einfacher, wenn meine Finger aus Gas wären, die zusammenzupressen zu einem? Das Dichte nicht so groß ist, ne? Das hat Hitler, glaube ich, auch gedacht. Das ist der Clou. Also zumindest, äh, nee, Ragu über Flüssigkeit schnutz auch nicht, also über Flüssigkeit eigentlich auch nicht. Flüssigkeiten genau, da kommt es ein bisschen drauf an, was wenn du Flüssigkeit hast...
Öl und Wasser? Ja, da gibt es halt, wenn du zwei hetero, wie heißt das, ne, hier wasserfreundliche Sachen, also hier Dipol und so, wisst ihr noch, diese ganzen Kräfte, die da wirken, wenn die richtige Sachen zusammenkippst, kannst du die ja auch super vermischen und wieder zu einem machen.
Und dann wieder trennen und mischen und trennen und mischen, gar kein Problem. Also du kannst ja zum Beispiel, wenn du Wasser hast, nimmst du einen Liter Wasser, nimmst du jeweils einen halben Liter davon, also zwei verschiedene Krügel, jeweils einen halben Liter, schüttest du raus und kippst wieder zusammen, hast du wieder denselben Liter wie am Anfang. Wenn du es mit Fingern machst, wenn du mit Fingern zerhackst, zwei Teile und danach zusammendrückst, wird es schwierig. Das heisst, wenn ich jetzt versuchen will, ich habe einen Pfannkuchen und versuche aus dem Pfannkuchen wieder Mehl, Ei und Milch zu machen, das ist schwierig, weil da hat sich ja chemisch was verändert. Das mischt ja nicht nur, dass du es zusammen mischt, da ist ja nicht nur Mehl und Ei zusammengeworfen, also schon auch, Aber da ist bestimmt, also ich bin jetzt kein Kochexperte, was da chemisch genau passiert, aber ich bin mir ziemlich sicher, dass wenn du das Zeug heiß machst, dass da, deswegen kochst du ja auch, also Kochen hat ja damit zu tun, dass du chemisch auch was am Essen verändern. Also jetzt mal. Deswegen gibt es ja auch sowas wie diese Chemieküche, wie heißt das, Mikroküche, nee, wie heißt das? Molekularküche. Molekularküche, das baut ja dann ja genau drauf auf, dass du quasi die Chemie des Kochens verstehst. Hast du noch eine Frage? Jetzt mal ganz kurz, damit wir uns das ungefähr vorstellen können, wie viel Energie muss man denn aufwenden, damit man die Finger zusammendrückt, dass sie zusammenbleiben? Gibt es irgendeine Möglichkeit, dass wir uns das vorstellen können, wie viel Energie man dafür braucht? Das ist schon ganz schön viel. Also du kannst dir ja vorstellen, bei Metall wird es wie viel Grad, 7000 Grad, ne, keine Ahnung, bei was wird Metall, schmilzt Metall, dann nimm halt mal das so als blöd, nimm halt zwei Metall, das musst du an Energie aufwenden, um Metall zu schmelzen, das wirst du auch brauchen, um dein Finger zu schmelzen, mal Minimum, ja, nicht Minimum, Maximum mehr, aber, oder? Gute Frage, weiß ich gar nicht. Ja, es sind ein paar ta Tausend Grad wäre nur ganz gut. Aber man schafft es auch ohne Erhitzung, oder wie? Also wenn man jetzt einfach nur zwei Euro-Stücke... Wenn du genug Dinge aufeinander presst, dann hast du ja auch Energie. Energie ist ja jetzt mal dem, ist ja ziemlich egal, wo sie herkommt. Ob du sie jetzt presst oder heiß machst oder... Aber deswegen ist diese Hydraulik presst ja auch so geil im Internet. Also du, ne?
Ne, schon gut, sorry, sorry.
Ja, also das ist schwer zu sagen.
Also ich finde jetzt in Grazelsen das irgendwie naheliegend, wenn du es presst.
Also da weiß ich noch nicht, wie viele das schon ausprobiert haben.
Ich denke mal, das ist schon ziemlich kompliziert.
Also das ist bestimmt jetzt nicht gerade wenig Kraft.
Das ist auch technisch, glaube ich, grundsätzlich schwierig umzusetzen, weil du ja nicht dann, also du müsstest ja dann quasi jede einzelne Atomfaser wieder mit der richtigen verbinden und das ist ja dann alles eigentlich. Und auch wenn du dann so viel fest drückst, hast du das Problem, dass er dann das wieder nicht aufeinander hält und so. Ja, ja. Okay, gut, wunderbar. Vielen Dank. Hast du noch irgendeine Frage, die du mal gerne loswerden wolltest? Was, wie, ich eine Frage an euch. Ja, einfach irgendwas, was wir dir beantworten können vielleicht. Ja, Mensch Stefan, warum bist du eigentlich nicht immer vor der Kamera zu sehen? Ich habe dich jetzt schon vermischtig schon bei einem neuen Projekt, das ihr momentan abmacht hier. Wir arbeiten dran.
Mensch, Mensch, Mensch, wo ist der Mann? Wir waren doch hier schon beim Neo-Magazin. Nee, wo warst du zu sehen? Ich hab doch beim Neo-Magazin, dass du bist aufgetreten. Ja, doch, auf jeden Fall. Cool, dankeschön. Und wo fielst du? Warum? Erklär mal, warum bist du nicht von der Kamera? Warum bist du so scheu? Es müssen halt auch Inhalte entstehen und leider darf ein Set nicht. Also ich habe oft gesagt, hör mal, können die mich nicht besetzen, aber das Ding ist, der Wille ist da, von allen Seiten, nein, der Wille ist schon da, aber wir haben nicht genug Geld, dass wir Autoren entbehren können und andere einstellen können, das ist einfach ein rein wirtschaftlicher Grund.
Stefan ist einfach zu talentiert, er hat zu viele Talente und deswegen können wir ihn nicht gleichzeitig an ihren Stellen verwenden.
Man hat versucht mich zu klonen, aber es ist daraus ein ganz schlimmer Unglück. Das ist ein ganz schlimmes Unglück. Aber das ist die erste Sendung. Du bist doch der Grund, warum hier gute Arbeit Originals überhaupt funktioniert. Das ist korrekt. Du bist die Eisenschmelze der ... Oh, da hat sich der Kreis geschlossen. Danke, Philipp Hauptmann. Du bist die Hitze, die alle anderen Elemente zusammendrückt. Das stimmt. Wunderbar. Physik kann auch romantisch sein.
Das mag ich daran.
Das mag ich an dir, Philipp.
Ja, ich weiss.
Ich weiss, Stefan, wir zwei können.
Da geht noch was.
Du, ich wünsche dir einen wunderschönen Tag.
Vielen, vielen Dank für deine tolle Antwort.
Und wir sprechen uns bestimmt bald nochmal.
Mach's gut. Vielen Dank.
Viel Spaß.
Bis dann.
Tschüss.
Ciao.
Ja, hinten raus hatte ich ein bisschen verrannt bei der Erklärung, aber da war ein bisschen viel Spekulation dabei. Aber ansonsten, fehliger Mann. Vielen Dank. Alles klar. Wenn ihr Physikfragen da draußen habt, ruft Philipp Hauptmann an. In Folge 103 sind wir ein kompletter Physik-Podcast, nur noch ein, völlig abgedriftet. Wann haben wir eigentlich entschieden, nie wieder Gags zu machen? Letzte Folge, oder? Letzte Folge, glaube ich. Ist diese schwerwiegende Entscheidung gefallen, aber wir halten uns sehr undraff dran. Hat manchen Leuten gefallen, manchen gar nicht, aber ist auch immer ganz cool, sowas. Ja, finde ich okay. Okay, ich habe noch was zu sagen. Ach ja, also, ich weiß nicht, sollen wir die Jingle-Maschine anschmeissen oder ich würde sagen. Stephans Fehlkäufe. Fehlkauf, Stephan. Es ist geschickt. Fehlkauf, Stephan. Ich glaube, schlimmer kann es nicht werden. Ich glaube, ich habe jetzt meinen Höhepunkt erreicht. Fehlkraft Stefan hat seinen absoluten Höhepunkt erreicht. Na, wir dachten ja eigentlich,
dass der Höhepunkt erreicht wurde durch den Swagway.
Segway ist mittlerweile
kaputt,
wurde kaputt gemacht und
ist aber auch nicht so gut gewesen, weil
man kann damit nicht auf der Straße fahren.
Und das war ja der einzige Grund, warum ich mir das ursprünglich gekauft habe,
um schneller von A nach B zu kommen,
um das Gehen einzustellen.
Wie oft bist du denn mit dem besagten Swagway gefahren?
Wie gesagt, Florentin, du bist auch ein bisschen bescheuert oder was?
Du bist ein bisschen retarded, das ist nicht machbar.
Du kannst damit nicht fahren, weil es zu schwierig ist, auf Gestein, auf unebenem Gestein zu fahren.
Okay, das heißt, du bist dann eher in deiner Wohnung damit gefahren?
Ja, auf ebenem Laminat oder auf Watte oder so. Man kann so gut damit fahren, aber nicht auf Stein. Ich und die gesamte Podcast-Community dachte wahrscheinlich, okay, gut, Stefan hat seinen Zenit erreicht, das ist der größte Fehlkauf, den man sich überhaupt gönnen kann. Nein, Stefan hat es geschafft, er hat mal wieder die Grenzen ausgetestet. Es ist ihm gelungen, sich selbst zu übertreffen. Es gibt, manche bei euch haben, ich habe es bei Snapchat gepostet, es ist unglaublich, was es gibt mittlerweile. Und zwar gibt es ein Board und es ist motorisiert. Und das ist nicht nur wahnsinnig schnell, sondern es sieht auch wahnsinnig cool aus. Du hast einen Controller in der Hand, wo dein Gaspedal dran ist. Man kennt es so ein bisschen wie so ein Karrierbahn-Controller. Und das hast du in der Hand, das ist Bluetooth mit dem Board verbunden und du kannst Gas geben. Und es kann wahnsinnig schnell beschleunigen, hat mehrere tausend Watt tatsächlich Beschleunigung. Und du kannst damit sehr schnell fahren, um die 30 kmh. Wie heißt das denn? Boosted Board, boosted! I'm getting boosted, baby! Also, für alle, die Stefan Titzel momentan noch nicht gesehen haben in der Öffentlichkeit, ihr erkennt ihn jetzt momentan daran, dass er immer mit seinem Longboard, seinem doch motorisierten Longboard, 40 Meter durch die Stadt fährt, dann an dem Bordstein scheitert, dann das wieder in die Hand nimmt, dann sich zwischen irgendwelchen Kinderwagen durchschlängelt, sagt, Entschuldigung, Entschuldigung, Entschuldigung, dann nochmal die Bluetooth-Verbindung nicht, dann hat sich das Board mit seinen Kopfhörern verbunden, dann hört irgendwie Brahms mit seinen Kopfhörern, mit seinem Board. Das Ding ist, wenn der Controller, das kann durchaus passieren, wenn der Controller die Verbindung kattet mit dem Board, dann kannst du nicht bremsen.
Und du fährst halt,
du kannst halt unmenschlich beschleunigen.
Das ist auch das Ding, wenn du bergab fährst und du,
das hat auch eine regenerative
Energie. Das heißt, wenn du bremst,
kannst du Energie gewinnen.
Wenn dein Board aber voll geladen ist und du den
Berg runter fährst und du bremst,
dann lädt es sich auf,
überlädt es sich,
geht aus und du kannst
Vielen Dank. Berg runterfährst und du bremst, dann lädt es sich auf, überlädt es sich, überlädt es sich, geht aus und du kannst nicht mehr bremsen und fährst mit 80 km her an Berg runter in den Tod. Ich finde es ungegut, dass du nicht bremsen kannst, einfach notgedrungen bis nach Moskau durchfahren, du musst einfach tagelang, du kannst einfach nicht mehr anhalten. Deswegen sollte man Helm tragen. Über die A8. Einfach bockenadenlos. Leute, Leute fahren in ihrem Twingo, hören 500 Meils und plötzlich sehen sie nur so einen gelben Blitz vorbeifahren. Wow, was war das? War das ein... Ach, ja, war das Stefan aus dem Segway? Ja, Stefan, aber das heißt, du wirst ja auch einen modischen Helm besorgen. Mit so Flammen drauf. Oder einen ironischen, so Hello Kitty, aber weiß man noch nicht. Oder einen richtig coolen Helm, den ich gesehen habe. Helme finde ich an sich cool, aber einen, den ich besonders cool finde, ist der, der so aussieht wie die Haare von einem Playmobil-Rändchen. Das kann ich mir, weil du siehst ja sowieso schon relativ Playmobil-esk aus. Das kann ich mir bei dir sehr gut vorstellen, auch von den Händen her, so Handschuhe.
Ich habe die ganze Zeit, meine Handform ist die ganze Zeit Playmobil-mässig. Ja. Ja, das stimmt, ich habe auch so eine Playmobil-Frisur. Eigentlich passt alles dazu, kann man auch aufsetzen. Es gibt auch, das ist ein alter Flight of the Concoords-Gag, den auch im März noch einmal geklaut hat, den Gag, dass Haare quasi auf dem Helm sind und so einen grossen Afro hat. Das finde ich auch nicht schlecht eigentlich. Das finde ich gut. Wir haben einen Praktikanten, muss man dazu sagen, jetzt bekommen, bei guter Arbeit, der eine unfassbar geile Frisur hat. Ja, mega gut. Wo man auch einfach denkt, Praktikanten sind ja so ein Mysteries, also wir arbeiten selber ja nicht in Personalabteilungen whatever, das heißt, diese
Praktikanten tauchen eines Tages auf,
verschwinden auch genauso schnell wieder, man
weiß nicht genau, welche Systeme da dahinter sind,
ob es da Saisons gibt oder so. Echt?
Ja. Man weiß nicht, ob es da Saisons gibt
oder so, auf jeden Fall taucht, läuft dann an deinem
Spiegelbüro einfach jemand vorbei
mit so einer Crusty der
Clown-Frisur, denkst du einfach, jopp,
herzlich willkommen, Thiebüro, er ist dabei. Und das Ding ist der ist da, glaube ich, ein Schülerpraktiker bei uns, Thilo. Und der hat ganz wunderbare, tolle Haare. Der hat so eine Tingletang-Bopp-Frisur, eine grosse, sehr selbstbewusste Frisur, für die er aber nichts kann. Also das spiegelt, glaube ich, nicht sein Selbstbewusstsein wider. Noch nicht, aber man müsste den ersten Schritt mal gehen. Man braucht erst die Frisur und dann kommt die Persönlichkeit. Er hat rote Haare, rötliche Haare und sehr viele davon in einer lockigen Form. Und er hasst Bart Simpson. Also er hat sich schon die Figur gut ausgesucht. Aber ja. Es ist wirklich, das Leben hier ist verrückt, crazy, crazy. Wollte ich? Ja, ich fahre jetzt jedenfalls bald mit meinem Board rum durch die Gegend, also weiß ich noch nicht.
Also was Mobilität angeht, darf ich leider nicht so sehr auf dem Hohen Ross sitzen, weil Stefan Titzel mag ein komplettes Mobilitätsopfer sein, aber ich glaube, ich bin momentan dabei, dich zu überbieten, denn mein momentanes Setup an Vorbewegungsmitteln ist ein Fahrrad, in Anführungszeichen, bei dem der Hinterreifen der Schlauch unter dem Mantel rausschaut, sodass ein Teil des Reifens massiv ungewuchtet ist, sodass ich, während ich fahre, immer so auf und ab gehe, als würde ich reiten. Und außerdem hat der Hinterrad noch einen Achter, das heißt, ich bewege mich seitlich und auf und ab, das heißt, ich bin in konstanter Bewegung. Aber das ist cool eigentlich.
Man könnte es dort auf den Beton mischen.
Da könnte man einfach hinten so einen Eimer hinstellen.
Das ist ja perfekt durchgemischt.
Das ist eigentlich ganz geil.
Aber mit der Farbe auch.
Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Und leider habe ich momentan das Problem, dass es meine Kette konstant raushaut.
Ich habe heute gezählt, vom Weg zur Arbeit hierher, zehnminütige Fahrradfahrt,
achtzehn Mal ist die Kette rausgeflogen.
Aber denkst du beim zehnten Mal nicht einfach, ach komm, du musst doch schneller aufige Fahrradfahrt, achtzehn Mal ist die Kette rausgeflogen und ich habe auch keine Bremse.
Denkst du beim zehnten Mal nicht einfach, ach komm,
du bist doch schneller, wenn das Fahrrad liegen lässt.
Ich bin trotzdem noch schneller, ich bin trotzdem noch schneller,
ich war auch für sehr, sehr langsam.
Zehn Sekunden, du bist nicht viel schneller mit dem Fahrrad.
Ich versuche momentan schon so weit zu kommen,
die Kette wieder während der Fahrt
einhängen zu können, so dass ich gar nicht abstelle.
Momentan ist es so, ich stell dir so
in der Lässing-Geste, der einfach den Fuss leicht nach hinten klappt und dann so Augenrollt und so gelangweilt und die Kette, wer drin ist. Und so Leute am Strassenrand stehen, die Frauen, denken so in Zeitlupe, wo staunen sie, wie man das macht, aber es ist einfach nur ein massives Opfer. Momentan ist mein aktuelles Setup, also erstens, es regnet, dadurch funktionieren meine Bremsen nicht mehr, überhaupt nicht nothing. Dann habe ich die Voice-Cancelling-Kopfhörer an, das heißt, ich bekomme vom Verkehr nichts mit. Rufende Polizisten, rufende Zivilisten, nichts, gar nichts. Ich bin in meiner eigenen Welt. Die schreien in Kinder, die du überfahren hast. Man weiß auch nicht mehr, ist es eine Bodenwelle, ist es ein Kind oder ist es einfach die Achte beim Reifen? Dann rufe ich in die Gegend, meine Jacke ist mir zu klein, das heißt, mein halber Rücken schaut raus, ist komplett entblößt, so fahre ich durch die Gegend, dann fahre ich durch die Gegend, genervt, dann springt die Kette raus, wie gesagt. Und er fährt freihändig, weil er hat in der einen Hand neuerdings ein Nutella-Glas und in der anderen hat er so einen grossen Löffel, so einen Eislöffel und schaufelt sich das Oh, ich habe ein Bild von dir gemacht, wie er heute Nutella frisst aus dem Glas, das ist eine tolle Sache, du bist dazu noch wahnsinnig fett. Deine T-Shirts reichen nicht mehr bis zum Hosenbund. Hose! Schon seit Wochen nicht mehr gesehen. Aber die Sache ist lieb, das heißt, ich fahre richtig gegen die Kette, springt raus, man bedenke, ich habe keine Bremsen. Das heißt, ich springe mit aufgerissenen Augen und hochrotem Kopf, springe ich vom Sattel, so dass ich meine Füsse auf den Boden schleife, um damit Fahrrad zum Stehen zu bringen, sehe dabei aus wie Lurchi der Frosch, ich weiss nicht, ob du dieses Comic kennst, wo sie am Ende alle, weil zum Thema Lurchi, also Lurchi ist dieser Schuhhersteller, Salamander, das heisst, du musst dir Comics ausdenken, in denen die Pointe jeder Geschichte ist, hab vernünftiges Schuhwerk, Kind, ja, das heißt,
und man denkt jedes Mal so, was mag es wohl diesmal
sein, das ist Rätsel, Lösung, ein Schuh.
Kreativ, relativ schnell am Ende dir zu überlegen,
was könnten Probleme sein, in einer Geschichte, ich erinnere mich
noch genau, bauen Lüchi und seine
Freunde, ähm, also
Froschi, Taubi und Vogeli,
äh, bauen so ein grosses
Flugzeug und landen
damit dann irgendwo, und das ist zu schnell und sie müssen sich alle mit ihren Füssen so dagegen stemmen, damit sie abbremsen. Und dann gibt es so die eine Variante, wo es ihnen halt wirklich blutig die Füsse wegreißt, einfach gnadenlos. Und dann sagen sie immer, hätten wir doch mal Schuhe von Salamander getragen. Wow, da hätten wir dieses Flugzeugabschuss überlebt. Und genau so sehe ich auch aus. wenn ich mit hochrundem Kopf versuche, mein Gefährt irgendwie zum Stehen zu bringen, bleib dann stehend, versuch dann irgendwie die fucking ölige Kette reinzufummeln und fahr dann die nächsten 20 Meter weiter, bevor es genau nochmal passiert. So komme ich momentan zur Arbeit. Also ich glaube, egal welches Fortwägungsmittel du benutzt, du bist mir immer noch einen Schritt voraus, auch wenn ich sehr darauf gespannt bin, wie du mit einem Bussebord mit 700 kmh ohne Bremsmöglichkeiten hier ankommst und eine Hilfe schreiend in so ein Auffangnetz fährst, das wir aufgebaut haben.
Ne, ich habe überlegt, es ist ein Fallschirm-Rucksack, den man einfach irgendwann so startet und dann massiv gross auch und das Ganze die BTF so einhüllt in so einer Dunkelheit.
Ja, das ist keine schlechte Idee.
Ey, das ist Wahnsinn. Also was die Technik mittlerweile, es ist ein bisschen teuer. Aber das gab es vor Jahren auch schon. Aber noch nicht so ausgereicht. Da war es halt noch ein schöner Otto-Motor, wo du halt erstmal acht Zylinder remmen, da will ich raus sparen und du halt pfff, die Gegend gefahren bist auf deinem Longboard. Aber das ist auf jeden Fall eine ganz gute Idee. Casey Neistat hat nämlich auch so eins.
Ja, sehr zu empfehlen, toller Channel. Man muss sagen, dass du mittlerweile auch modisch immer weitere Fortschritte machst. Es ist ja sehr beliebt, mittlerweile so Skinny-Jeans zu haben, die irgendwann so über den Knöchel aufhören, die so ein bisschen zu kurz sind und die man hochkrempelt, damit man so ein bisschen den Knöchel freilegt. Auch die Jungs. Und deine Jogginghose ist mittlerweile so ausgetragen und aufgetragen, dass sie
so klein ist, dass sie auch so
den Knöchel freilegt. Und man denkt
immer so, will er jetzt mit seiner Jogginghose
den Style kopieren, den
andere gerade vorschlagen mit echten Hosen?
Man denkt immer, du versuchst es so
irgendwie noch mit
den Fingernägeln sich am Türrahmen der Mode
festzuhalten, aber das ist nicht schass. Aber es funktioniert einfach. Nein, du bist weggerissen. Nee, es ist tatsächlich einfach nur verwaschen und eingegangen und kaum noch zu retten. Aber warum heißen meine ganzen E-Mobilitätsdinger immer so seltsam? Die E-Mobilitätsdinger. Ach, ja. Boosted Board, Swagway, das waren nicht so viele Fehlkäufe in der Richtung. Als nächstes kommt irgendein Jetpack, ich bin mir hundertprozentig sicher. Irgendein scheiß Jetpack, das Wasser rausspritzt oder so und alles nass macht. Das ist geil, das gibt es ja im Wasser. Das hat so einen Schlauch unten an deinen Füssen, glaube ich, das zieht ganz das Wasser raus aus dem Ozean, das macht den Ozean leer, und dann hast du aber an deiner Hand und an deinen Füssen so Düsen, die erst wieder rausdrüsen, und dann kannst du damit quasi über dem Wasser schweben, also auf Wasser gehen. Ja, also die Wassermobilität ist massiv gestiegen, scheitzeben, es will halt nur einfach kein Mensch auf dem Wasser sein. Ja, ich will jetzt halt mit meinen massiven Mitteln, die mir finanziell zur Verfügung stehen, die will ich einfach, also mit meinem ganzen Sketchgeld, mit meinem ganzen Witzegeld, das will ich die Leute haben. Hau mal auf Patreon was raus. Apropos. Ich glaube, es ist nicht schlecht. Ich glaube, es ist gut. Boosted Board. Ich bin sehr gespannt. Ich freue mich auf viele Vlogs und viele Snaps von dir auf deinem Longboard, wie du mit einem Starbucks in der Hand durch die Gegend fährst, durch Köln fährst. Durch Ehrenfeld fährst.
In meiner leicht zu kleinen Hose.
Ja.
Ach, cool.
Ah, das wird ein Traum.
Ich glaube, es ist nicht schlecht.
Und ich finde, es ist auch, ich habe das so stolz im Büro erzählt,
und es ist ein massiver Schützturm auf mich eingepasselt, womit ich nicht so gerechnet hätte.
Ich kann mir das genauso fragen.
Habe ich ein bisschen berascht.
Du läufst so mit deinem Schulranzen zu arbeiten.
Und dinks, ach, heute erzähle ich meinen Freunden, dass ich mir ein Boosted-Board vorbestellt hab, für allein schon 100 Dollar. Nein, das fliehst du ja in das Geld rein, das verstehst du nicht. Ja, aber das heißt, du hast dir schon 100 Dollar gezahlt. Ja, aber es riecht ja zurück, wenn ich es nicht mehr will. Ja, weiß ich nicht genau. Auf jeden Fall erzählst du ihn, oh, dann werden alle gucken und die Praktikantin wird mich toll angucken und denkt, oh, kann ich auch mal mitfahren? Und dann sagst du es in der Arbeit und alle so, Alter Stefan, du bist so beschissen einfach, du lernst auch nicht dazu aus seinen Fehlern. Hass, Hass, Hass. Ja, ja, ja, ja, finde ich auch cool. Ja, aber im Gegensatz zu dem ersten, was ich mir aus China irgendwo bestellt habe, kann das, bislang ist nicht erwiesen, dass es in die Luft fliegen könnte. Ja. Also das in der Hinsicht mache ich mir schon mal einen Fortschritt. Gesundheitsechnik. Es könnte sich nur mit dem WLAN von irgendjemandem beifahrenden WG verbinden und dann komplett durchdrehen. Ja, und dann ist die Bremse einfach nicht mehr okay. Die Bremse sind für dich, oder du vermindest dich aus Versehen mit dem Board von dem anderen. Das war bei dem Vorgängermodell tatsächlich ein Problem, dass man, wenn man parallel gef gefahren ist, man hat Gas gegeben, einfach dann neben dir durch die Decke gegangen ist.
Ah, der kreativste Mord seit langem einfach.
Ey, echt nicht schlecht.
Schreib da mal einen Roman.
Du weißt, ein guter Mörder, glaube ich.
Vielleicht bin ich schon.
Nee, das würde nie kein Mörder sagen.
Vielleicht?
Vielleicht glaubst du aber auch nur, dass er es nicht sagen würde, deswegen sagst du es.
Der beste Mörder ist der, der nicht weiß, dass er ein Mörder ist. Oh. Oder der glaubt, er würde damit was Gutes tun. Hast du dir welche Serientipps zu empfehlen? Black Mirror. Sehr gut momentan. Schauen glaube ich auch alle gerade an. Erste Staffel sehr gut, die anderen beiden sind auch noch gut, aber nicht mehr so gut wie die erste. Also wenn ihr wenig Zeit habt, dann gebt euch schön die erste Staffel und hört dann auf.
Aber wenn ihr sagt,
finde ich ganz so cool, dass ich auch
mittelmässige davon nochmal cool fände,
schaut weiter. Ja, ich habe jetzt mit Westworld angefangen,
wo man sich auch fragt, das ist mir so
ein Mindfuck
laut tausend Meter ebenen Inception
Ding, wo man sich ein bisschen
fragt, was ist im Hause Nolan, das ist von dem Bruder
von Christopher Nolan, eigentlich falsch gelaufen, dass sie so besessen darauf sind, auf so Zeugs. Ja, wie muss man sich das Weihnachtsessen bei Nolans vorstellen? Das ist eine Weihnachtsgranz, und da drin ist eine Weihnachtsgranz, in der eine Weihnachtsgranz steht. Und darin Joseph Gordon-Level. Mit einem Kreisel im Mund, der aufhört zu kreiseln. Klingt wie ein toller Sketch? Wahrscheinlich seht ihr den bei jetzt, weil wir haben keine Ideen mehr. Nichts. Everything is a Sketch. Ja, schaut mal rein, was wir gerade so machen. Schaut mal rein. Gut, Stefan. Warst du schon eine Stunde? Nö. Lass mal eine Stunde voll machen. Lass mal genau eine Stunde machen. Ich muss mal aber los schon langsam. Das ist nicht okay. Du kannst dich erst für Patreon werben und dann sagst, ich muss eigentlich los. Später, auch kaum musst du los, ich hab keinen Bock mehr. Keine Lust mehr. Lass die Spacken spätten. Wir haben übrigens von den angekündigten 100 T-Shirts, die wir verkaufen müssen, bevor neue Designs auf den Markt kommen, schon null verkauft. Bleibt dran, Leute. Aber vielen Dank schon, Andi. Andi, null. Leute, das ist eine gute Sache. Topical Island. Oh, nee. Ich werde den nicht ein. Auch jetzt mit dem neuen Programm weiß ich gar nicht. Ach, ja, gut. Topical Island, Topical Island, Topical Island, Topical Island, Topical Island. Das ist alles neu in der Welt. Was gibt's Neues? Pietro und Sarah haben sich getrennt. Nein. Oh nein, das darf doch nicht wahr sein. Ich weiß nicht mehr, wer das ist. Weißt du, wenn ich auch gestern auf dem Comedypreis gesehen habe? Menderes. Ja! Diesen Typen von Dschungelcamp, wo man sich ja damals alle dachten so, boah, krass, der ist ja nur berühmt und will's schaffen und will's macht irgendwas. Und da dachte man sich ja immer so, ah, okay, reicht das denn, alleine berühmt sein und der Wunsch, berühmt zu sein? Ja. So ist es die nächste Daniel Katzenberger, ist es die neue Kim Kardashian. Gestern haben wir auf dem Promedy-Preis gesehen, wie er einfach rumstand und irgendwie dann von so einem Starbucks-Typen verwechselt wurde.
Ja, vielleicht hat es nicht ganz geklappt mit der Karriere, aber freut euch mal auf Folge 28.
Wie lustig wäre es eigentlich, wenn man Comedy-Preis nur so Instrumentalmusik, so lustige Musik laufen würde. So. Thema. Sind die aus dem Zahn so, ähm, jift? Ach Gott, ey, scheisse Wörter. Horror-Clowns bevölkern die Welt, oh nein, was machen wir denn da? Ja, interessiert mich. Du musst aber auch an Topik einpartizipieren. Ja, interessiert mich aber nicht. Nichts, was hat da passiert? Ja, mach mal weiter. Mal gucken, was hier noch so neu ist. Ach ja, gestern sind Menschen gestorben in einer Wildwasserachterbahn. Die wurden... Oh, hey! Okay, und dann oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, ohu! Und dann sind die auf dieser Transportbahn, dieses grosse Kassenband, wo man quasi wie Waren durch den Spaßpark gezogen wird. Das hat sich irgendwie verheddert, was ich auch nicht ganz verstehe, und ist dann umgekippt, hat zwei Leute sofort getötet und zwei Leute Zwei geköpftöpft, äh, zerquetscht. Zwei getötet, drei geköpft, hat durch Geschlecht überlebt. Seltsam aber. Glücklicher war ja. Kann man, ja, und das ist aber schon irgendwie krank, aber auch ganz, sorry, aber ich fand es irgendwie ein bisschen lustig. Ja, ich fand es auch lustig. Waren auch keine jungen Leute, also waren nur ältere. Okay, dann ist ja gut. Dann passt das ja. Ja, das war's von mir. Topical Island. Das war's aus der Topical Island-Reaktion. Gut, vielen Dank an die Topical Island-Reaktion. Musik aus! Findest du nicht auch, dass Saftgläser im Hotel immer ein bisschen zu klein sind? Kommt jetzt ein Stand-up oder was? Man kann aber auch nicht normal anfangen mit Stand-up, ne? Man muss immer so eine seltsame rhetorische Frage stellen. Findest du nicht, dass Saftgläser im Hotel, ich weiß es ehrlich gesagt nicht mal genau, was du denn meinst, Saftgläser. Das ist eine sehr spezielle Frage. In deinem Minibar dann oder was? Der schlechteste Comedian der Welt, der so ganz schlechte rhetorische Fragen am Anfang stellt, wo alle so auch keine wenige Meinung zu haben. Normalerweise würde ja ein Comedian immer so eine rhetorische Frage am Anfang stellt, alle sagen, ja, klar, klar, aber bei mir immer alle so, keine Ahnung, was hast du zu erzählen? Saftgläser im Hotel, klein sind. Puh, ich bin auf die Panschlein gespannt, mein Lieber. Gibt's nicht, ich bin einfach nicht... Ne, weiß nicht, ich hab das immer in meinem Gagdokument gefunden. Aber ich weiß auch nicht genau, was damit gemeint war. Vor allem natürlich, hast du Frank Elstner? Notizen, ich hab mal auch... Ja, hab ich schon mal erzählt. Ne, was ist denn? Ne, habe ich schon mal erzählt. Aber vielleicht kommen wir da auf was Neues. Ne, ich hatte mal so einen kleinen Taschenrechner, Computer ähnliches Ding, also wirklich ganz alt, ganz klein, wo man so Sachen abspeichern konnte, wo man so eine große Tastatur hatte. Und da konnte man so Rechenoperationen machen, aber man konnte auch Sachen eintippen. wirklich so ein, stellt euch wie einen Taschenrechner vor, der noch ein Level drüber ist, so zwischen Taschenrechner und Tamagotchi, noch nicht ganz bewusst sein, aber auch mehr als ein Taschenrechner und da konnte man auch so Notizen abspeichern und da konnte man auch Notizen abspeichern, die man mit einem Passwort schützt und das habe ich gemacht, habe ich mein Passwort ausgedacht und die einzige Notiz, die ich gespeichert habe, war, das Mädchen, das ich damals verknallt war, zu der Zeit, habe ich mir aufgeschrieben. Damit du den Namen nicht vergisst. Ja, damit ich das nicht vergesse. Damit ich das nicht vergesse. Wo ich mir auch denke, was war die Logik dahinter, wo ich dann so, fuck, wen, wen mich da verknallt? Ich muss kurz nachgucken. Ich weiß gar nicht mehr. Hamty-damty-99. Das ist das Problem, du wirst dich niemals verkaufen. Ach, Laura, ja, jetzt haben wir es wieder, alles klar. Ich war damals ein großer TV-Total-Fan, als ich noch kleiner war, und da habe ich mir irgendwann dieses Nippelboard gebaut. Mit diesen vielen Knöpfen, wo man drauf drücken konnte. Was ist deine Mutter? Ach Gott, ey. Ehrlich? Als ich ganz klein war, ich will es noch mal zu bringen, um zu gucken, ob dir eine bessere Punch einfällt. Als ich ganz klein war, war ich ein riesen TV-Total-Fan, hat man dann dieses Nippelboard gebaut, was er hat. Auf seiner Mutter? Ja, und dann kann man da diese Knöpfe draufdrücken und dann kommt Dört und dann kommt ein lustiger Ausschnitt. Und ich dachte immer, wie cool wäre es, wenn Freunde da sind bei mir und dann sitze jemand am Schreibtisch und die sitzen dann auch auf dem Bett oder so. Und dann redet man casual, hast du die Laura gestern gesehen? Die ist auch ganz schön gross geworden. Klassischer Man-Boys-Talk. Genau. Die ist aber ganz schön gross geworden. Die ist ja locker zwei Zentimeter gewachsen in den letzten Jahren. In den Sommerferien. Keine Ahnung, was man gesagt hat. Und dann dachte ich mir, wie cool wäre es, wenn ich dann im Gespräch einfach mal so einfließen lassen könnte, wie Raab das immer macht mit seinen coolen Nippeln. Da habe ich extrem viel Arbeit reingesteckt, mir das zu programmieren und habe dann auch so ein bisschen wirklich rumgetüftelt, mit viel angelesen, so Programmierwillen. Und dann habe ich das auch einigermaßen gut hinbekommen, aber es war dermaßen gescheitert, weil die Technik aber damals auch nicht, ich glaube es war relativ gut durchdacht, aber die Technik war so furchtbar, dass es einen massiven Delay hatte und dann auch im Gespräch, dann irgendwann habe ich das so, diesen Eier, wir brauchen Eier, kam dann einfach viel zu spät, auch beim nächsten Thema schon lange, wo man alle dachte, das ist ein riesen Trottel geworden. Aber da dachte ich auch so, da war ich zum ersten Mal bewusst, dass die Technik noch nicht so weit ist wie mein Geist. Um mich zu einem halbwegs sozial akzeptablen Mensch zu machen, braucht das einfach noch ein paar Jahre. Das hat nicht funktioniert, aber fällt mir gerade an. Wir haben ja letztens auch deinen alten YouTube-Account entdeckt, den du als Kind hattest, wo du als Kind Werbungen, die du lustig fandest, auf YouTube hochgeladen hast. Was massiv illegal ist eigentlich, oder? Ja. Ich habe Fortwerbungen hochgeladen zum Beispiel. Ich war so eine Fortwerbung, da wurde so ein Vogel abgeschossen, das fand ich tierisch lustig als Kind. Dann fing es so an, dass man Klicks gesammelt hat auf MyVideo, auf Clipfish und auf YouTube. Da habe ich mir einfach einen Account gemacht und habe, glaube ich, zwei Werbungen hochgeladen. Und habe dann so 113 Klicks bekommen und fand das toll. Mir ging es schon immer nur um den Erfolg, nie um das Produkt. Und auch das von mir ist eine Eigenleistung. Fuck it, ich wollte einfach die Klicks haben. Den Kanal kann man heute noch finden und wer den findet, kriegt ein Shirt von Gäste, Liste, Geisterbahn, gratis von uns. Von dem Geld, von denen. Ja, klar. Ja, cool, vielen Dank an dich, Martin Will. Ja, gern geschehen, vielen Dank an dich, Stefan Tietze, schön, dass du da warst. Nächste Woche haben wir was ganz fantastisches vorbereitet für Folge 80. 80 Folgen haben wir schon gemacht.
Ich war noch Folge 88. Das wird richtig fantastisch. Bis dahin wünschen wir euch noch eine schöne Woche. Macht's gut, kommt gut in das Wochenende und wieder raus.
Kommt gut durch den Stau, ist ja Ferienende oder Anfang, keine Ahnung, vielleicht auch keine Ahnung.